Speaker 1: OK, this is a story as much about
mental illness as it is about anything else,
and we're not we're not ridiculing mental
illness, we're not stigmatizing it.
We're really talking about the sad state of
affairs in the United States, where there
is so much undiagnosed and untreated mental
illness.
Our friend Walter Masterson was at the Trump
rally in Florence, South Carolina, over the
weekend.
This is the rally we covered live Saturday,
and we had clips of Trump's speech from yesterday,
and we got a little bit of insight into some
of the wackiest characters who were at the
rally yesterday.
But that was when they were being interviewed
by like right wing interviewers who didn't
really know the right questions to ask.
Walter actually knows what he's doing.
So let's get right into this.
This is, I believe this is a clinically insane
hypothesis that this person has.
And if they were to sit down with a psychiatrist,
I believe they would be medicated for presenting
what this person presents in this video.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 6: I got a good idea what's going
on in Ukraine when they went into Ukraine
and they found these labs?
They believe that maybe that the deep state
is possibly going to use a bioweapon on Russian
people because they've been just like that.
They were collecting our DNA in China.
They've been collecting their DNA as well.
OK, so
Speaker 1: Chinese DNA collection is analogous
to something that the deep state is going
to do to then bioweapon the Russian population.
Wow.
I mean, this is someone whose brain is mayonnaise.
I don't know any other way to describe it.
Speaker 7: So Trump and Putin right now are
the only ones successfully fighting against
the deep state.
Speaker 6: I think, as well as cheating to
change Xi Jinping.
Speaker 7: Hmm.
So Xi Jinping is fighting against the he's
a good guy.
Oh, oh, he's fighting against it.
Speaker 1: No surprise, by the way, that more
of these Trump is just love these dictatorial
authoritarians.
Speaker 6: Because think about it, he's not
part of the CCP secretly.
Speaker 7: But Xi Jinping, do you think he's
working with Putin and Trump against the deep
state?
Speaker 2: I think he probably is.
Yeah, probably.
I've heard that.
Yeah, I
Speaker 7: mean that for Xi Jinping is working
against the deep state Modi, Modi and India.
Yeah, I've heard that Xi Jinping, Modi, Vladimir
Putin, Donald Trump are all working against
the deep state, right?
Speaker 1: Those they love their dictators,
don't they?
Speaker 2: And you've got the whitehat alliance,
which is a lot of countries.
You know,
Speaker 1: I looked, by the way, for the whitehat
alliance, I found no, no record of it.
There is a small hacking group called the
WhiteHat Alliance.
It's very clearly not with this woman's referring
to.
Speaker 6: France, he is part of the good
guys.
The reason, I think that is because he is
going to go into Taiwan.
You wait and see what I tell you when he gets
into Taiwan.
Guess what?
He's going to find more labs, more bio labs,
that is all planned out.
You know, it's all planned.
And this is one big sting operation.
That's what I believe.
Speaker 7: Yeah.
So Xi Jinping, Putin and Trump, that's the
only ones fighting against the deep state
and making sure that there are no bioweapons
stash right now.
Speaker 1: If, oh, hold
Speaker 6: on, because if they do not stop
them, they will release them,
Speaker 1: right?
If if we were to do a skit with some person
joking about crazy conspiracy theories, you
couldn't do any better than that.
Their their mind is truly gone.
Or it was never there or whatever.
Here's another example.
And again, we're not joking when we say mental
illness.
But but but we're also not saying political
extremism is exclusively mental illness.
We're not saying that either.
This just happens to be the perfect nexus
of both.
Here's another one.
Speaker 2: When it came out, it was corona,
right?
Corona.
Corona is six letters.
When you're used to my trivia